[Music]
all right real good thank you so much
for coming hey let's give a round of
applause for Sean this is so I can write
down if you guys have any questions and
I don't have an answer I want to be able
to get back to you so that could happen
too and I want this to be kind of
informal if you have a question feel
free to just interrupt me and then shout
it out or raise your hand or however you
feel comfortable doing that and I'll see
if I'm moving too fast or if I go pass
something you want to see how that
worked
I'm willing to to go back and do it so
hi I'm Sean Hornsby this is an intro to
web game development class class Meetup
talk presentation let's go there
Who am I well I I've been talking to you
guys so a lot of you probably already
know this I have only been doing this
just under a year professionally I went
to a boot camp in Orange County and got
a job right after that working on
developing a web app using the myrn
stack so it's a [ __ ] Express react and
node and that's been fun it was a
contract gig that's sort of a startup
that didn't get funding and we're still
kind of trickling through there so I'm
doing part-time work there I am a
hobbyist game developer that's that's
who I am it's interesting in this
context I also have have four kids
between the ages of 3 & 7 so I just
that's just to let you know what you
guys can do this I have a part-time job
I have four kids and I'm still learning
this stuff and doing it and and I saw
the brain power to do it which is
actually pretty amazing I know if any of
you have kids one or two or four you
know what I mean it's pretty pretty nuts
so do a little overview of what to
expect here the stuff we talked about
this is the program interview or talk
about why you would want to design games
why you would want to spend time
building games maybe time that you think
if I'm a real developer this is this
could be more productive learning Redux
or learning
angular four or something else so we'll
cover that I chose inside the game
development there's that there's a
framework called phaser why did I choose
phaser we'll talk about that and then
how it all works and some of the
accessories to that and at the end
however much time we have left will do
some QA so why should you spend time
writing games or thinking about games
well I I think I laid it out here pretty
well most of it is about fun it's fun to
do these things it's fun to think about
it I'm sure that we've all played games
probably we all play games occasionally
or more than occasionally we think about
games when we're playing them and I
could have done if this thing was
different or I could design this game
you know I could have done something
like that
that's that's a great piece of
engagement you're engaged in writing
your code if any of you have written
like professional code working on
business logic stuff it can get pretty
taxing mentally it's not a lot of fun
normally to think about like oh did I do
this you know do these products filter
into the right thing and get treated in
it's it's taxing but it's not always
very exciting so having some fun is a
great way to keep from burning out to
liked it gives you even if you're just
doing occasionally it gives you some
time to de-stress and think about
writing code in a way that doesn't have
to do with whatever your boss is telling
you to do and maybe six other people
filtering down their demands too and
that the point I think on here that is
is very important is it
you're gonna finish projects because
they're fun to do and finishing projects
is good for you emotionally mentally to
have this finished thing it's also good
for you professionally because it's
something you can show other people and
you can and you will you will solve
problems while you're writing games that
other people will need to solve too and
then you may end up blogging about it or
speaking about it and people will start
coming to you for answers in that way
and that's that's a very rewarding thing
also so when you're writing games in
JavaScript there are probably three main
ways you can go you can work from the
ground up you can dig it with the WebGL
specs or the for the canvas facts and
you can write
right there on the metal you can build
your games it's it's doable it's maybe
not as fun as it could be because
there's a lot of grunt work there the
other end of the spectrum is these fully
built realized tool sets something like
unity even game creator cocos2d these
are tool sets where you load them up
they fire up they look like Photoshop or
some kind of program and you build your
code you build your pieces in there you
move your stuff around you do get to
write some code but mostly there's a lot
of overhead and learning the tool set
and those are they're actually very
powerful unity is an incredibly powerful
tool set people build professional level
games with those tool sets and that's a
great thing
but there is some ramp up if you just
want to start writing and for me I like
writing JavaScript so I want to write
JavaScript I look for more of the
framework in phaser is a framework so
you end up it's it's easy to use you
require it in or you actually stick it
in as a script in your index file and
then you can just start writing code you
have a JavaScript file that you just
start building in there's a ton of
community support there's actually maybe
too much community support at some point
they decided they were gonna hand it
over to the community and so now there's
the community edition and that's that's
what I use
it's the latest the documentation is a
little messy but there's so much extra
support around there that it doesn't
matter that much you can find your way
and then drill through the documentation
kind of you learn what to look for and
then you look for in the docs there is
on their on their site they have this
all these tutorials about specific
features of phaser that are great and
there's even a couple of other sites
that drill and even further and that's
the so that the phaser CD the github is
the library a lot of the framework and
then the docs are there too and these
slides will be available later too so if
you see something and you didn't get a
chance to write it down or you don't
feel like writing right now there's not
a problem with that and I'm on slack so
any questions I'll answer there too
so now you've thought about why oh yeah
sorry
I think some of it is personal
preference some of it is what you're
trying to get out of it are you trying
to write a unity if you were looking for
a 3d like a wonderful 3d game even it
was like 3d isometric or something
unity probably a better place to look
than phaser phaser and where I've mainly
focuses on two-dimensional games so you
so if you look it's really based on what
you need out of it if you're looking to
build something that you want to take to
market and then maybe unity is a good
place to start although phaser games are
are selling there on native devices
they're on the web so it comes down to
your preference really you're gonna end
up with a lot of the same results
depending how much work you put into it
I think some of those tool sets like
unity do a lot of the heavy lifting but
there is a learning curve to learning
the tool so I just chose phaser because
it's quick it's easy to use I don't have
to worry about like even learning how to
use unity or teaching you have a use
unity you can literally get phaser games
going in like 10 minutes probably even
less if you if you have any experience
with front-end developmental so so
that's any other questions about then so
we got why would you build games and
what would you use to build them now
what are you gonna build so you're right
now you're sitting there thinking I got
a game idea it's gonna be great probably
looks something like this this huge
maybe it doesn't even feel that
complicated but I guarantee you it is a
complicated piece of machinery that
you're thinking about building so I need
you to scale it down and I want you to
think smaller now you're thinking
smaller that's a lot smaller a lot
smaller that's still too complicated for
your first game especially but for
engine and just learning how to do this
stuff there are too many moving parts
and I'm not actually sure why that
x-wing has two pilots in two astromech
units so that's a little weird too but
this is still too complicated you need
to think simple that I think is
obviously a Millennium Falcon but it is
also obviously very simple it's probably
12 pieces there that's great that's
where you want to start
on your first game your first project
you're learning phaser you're gonna
learn how to build a game if you get in
over your head it's gonna leave a bad
taste in your mouth you're gonna you're
gonna get halfway through something and
you're gonna get bogged down and you're
gonna throw it all away and say I don't
ever want to do this again this is this
is dumb I'm dumb forget it I'm gonna go
back to whatever something else writing
business logic even that might be more
fun so then the nice thing - I mean I
think depending on how old you are the
games that you played as a kid are
probably way different than the games I
played as a kid who had like an Atari
2600 or yeah nobody so so you so so
there is this what I like about is
there's this big library of games that
are already built and when you talk
about like Atari games they're already
simple maybe your first game was halo -
that's that's in the capital ship
category you're not gonna build even a
clone or some version of Halo - I grew
up playing things like like pitfall and
Donkey Kong and so those games are
reachable that's something you can do
and I think if you look in that era of
games you're gonna find a lot of a lot
of those already built that already have
kind of they have that ui/ux re to
design players know how to how to do
those things somebody thought about how
to make that game accessible to people
how what affordances are what if what
makes sense you don't have to worry
about the game design you don't have to
worry about any of that stuff you can
just focus on writing the game it's
already been designed and that's I think
that's a great place to start I started
with pong I feel like that it's a very
simple game it's still literally some
moving parts in there this is some stuff
to do but it's it's simple enough to to
get through and so let me break out of
this now and I'll actually I'll actually
fire up pong here
I should figure out what port I put that
server onto so that's it this is pong
and I'm on the left and the computer is
slowly trying to catch up on the right
things there's a lot running so it kind
of bogs down a little bit
this is pong and I think if you've ever
seen pong it's a pretty good
representation of it there are still
choices you can make when you're
designing this game so there we go a
positive we'll get back to the
presentation a little bit but that's
pong pong works and and I'll show you
how that was built um first though I'm
gonna cover a little bit of just the
basics this is a basic phaser game right
here this is all the code yes sir yeah I
use a BS code I just add them as well I
like them both I like vyas code although
this is probably an outdated opinion
vyas code has a built in node debugger
that I don't think Adam does and at the
time when I was using Adam it didn't I
like the vs code has a built in terminal
also so I don't have to switch back and
forth a lot you can just pop the
terminal open sublime is another popular
choice it's it's not free but it is free
I think they suggest you pay 80 bucks
for it but you can use it forever
without doing that
who is the web storm is a great IDE but
it it is it's an IDE something like vs
code or atom or our code editors they're
lightweight they're they're very low
feature simple to use if you if you're
coming from something like like Visual
Studio itself you might be more
comfortable in like a web storm has a
lot of features but yeah I'd stick with
us coder or atom so once you get your
index set up and I'll show you that too
this is this is all that's required to
start a phaser game you have game uses a
new phaser game and then you have a
width and a height for the window that
you're gonna build phaser auto just lets
it
select between if WebGL if WebGL support
is there it'll use WebGL if not it'll
drop down to canvas and then I use
phaser if my div name that's where it
inserts it into the into the webpage if
you don't add anything there or on the
webpage it just pushes it into the body
of the page which is okay at this level
because you know there's not like a lot
of other code going on my web page is
literally just the head and then a
script tag and then I just register a
couple free functions preload create an
update and those are the three I think
you could probably get away with create
an update but preload is important in
its own right and then what happens when
the game loads is it runs through the
preload function once it runs through
the create function once and then it
starts hitting update every frame so
about 60 times a second it runs through
the entire update function and so let me
show you the crack out of this and I'll
show you the index file too because I
don't think I included that in there
this is what the HTML file looks like
you guys I'll read that I hope because I
don't know how to make it any bigger
it's this is the only two important
parts well that's not true this is
important this is where you require this
is how you get phaser I use a content
delivery network
I like that method and then there's the
div that it's going to stick it in my
phaser div and then I just have to tell
it where my code is so that's how that
works
now that once you get past that like
this guy right here this blank looking
thing you have couple things you have to
think about how many of you like global
variables variables in the global scope
nobody that's the right answer
but now we're now we're game developers
so we need these semi global variable
they're Derb they're actually pretty
global they're gonna be out there
they're gonna hold a lot of our fun of
our stuff so that those separate
functions can access them without having
to pass back and forth all these all
these objects so we're gonna tie it well
I'll show you some Global's we'll talk
about that the preload and the create
functions so this is this is pong this
is the top half of pong you can see the
game and the top we just talked about
all those let statements are my global
variables if this was a year ago those
would be bar statements but this is es6
I like to use I like to stay away from
var whenever possible I don't know if
that distinction means anything to
anybody at this point but so that's
that's if you're used to seeing far
anywhere you see bar or let or Const
it's essentially the same thing for the
for the sake of this conversation so I'm
gonna do things with these so I just I
just declare them out there and then
you'll see I start using them and create
but in preload what freeload does is
while the game is going and if you're
gonna reuse assets it loads those assets
and holds onto them so I have these
games these audio files it's loading in
and it's giving them a name this P hit 1
is the name I can refer to that later
and it's going out to there and it's
pulling this association in there and
once you've done that and in some games
you might not have if you don't have
sprites if you're just using like
building graphics and meanings in fact
you can get away with fog without
preload if you don't I didn't hear any
sound this sound might just might
probably coming through but if you don't
have files to load then it doesn't
matter the next part is that create
section and that's just that's just the
top portion of create but what I'm
building there is the player and so I've
already got it out there but I'm
assigning it some phaser stuff here so
game is given to me up here it's
phaser game a game has a bunch of
methods and calls and at the simple
level when you're when you're doing
things you're gonna add something in my
case I'm not using sprites which I'll
show you sprites a little bit later but
there's not like complex graphics I'm
just gonna build a paddle you saw the
paddle it's a white rectangle so here's
what I do I tell it where I'm gonna put
it and these are so this is just the
width and the height or the X and the y
coordinates of the origin of that
whatever I'm gonna build next and I
moved it 40 pixels in and then halfway
up the screen - I know I'm gonna make it
60 pixels so I just cut it in half so
it's starting right in the center of the
screen on the left and then I'm gonna do
a little fill and that's a hex color
code that's just white and then the next
the one there is the opacity level it's
fully opaque I'm not doing any any alpha
type stuff I'm going to draw a rectangle
that starts at the origin I gave it and
it's going to be ten wide and ten pixels
wide and 60 pixels long or tall and then
the other fun thing when you start
working with phaser is you have some
physics models they actually give you
three physics models this is like like
your question about which which
framework or tool set to use this is
kind of the same which physics model to
use it depends on what you're trying to
do I'm doing something very rkt so I'm
going to use their very simple
lightweight arcade physics engine this
is what they recommend to use if you're
gonna if you're going to throw it onto
like a mobile app or something because
it's not doing any heavy lifting super
complex stuff but it gives you a lot of
fun things you can do once I've enabled
the physics that player has a body and
it has things like this collide World
bones and it has you can start giving it
velocity and acceleration and all that
kind of stuff
so that's a good question you can kind
of test these well it's gonna be in the
browser but the problem is if you're
developing this locally and you're just
using it as a file system so if you go
in here if I go in here and I said well
I don't need why would I need a server
to run this I'll show you why when we if
we just open
I have to get in there all the way let
me if I open index.html this doesn't
apparently this that go one too far I
did it's trying to load a file it's
trying to load three files but I'm in
the file system instead of HTTP and so I
did a lot of problems these aren't the
problems I expected to get I expected to
get a cross origin problem because then
the browser tries to play in the file
system it gets very specific about what
it can do it can't go get other files
it's it's the browser is getting in the
way here so that's why I run a
lightweight node like Express server to
host it so I can go to localhost and I
don't run it across origin stuff once
you have that going somewhere though if
you if I wasn't testing on the
filesystem you wouldn't need a server at
all you could stick it on on you were
saying you're using and genex you could
stick it up there like a static asset
and it would run just fine yeah
[Music]
it should so I haven't actually done any
like natives or mobile testing it at all
but something like pong should
definitely work that I don't know how
complex you can get and like optimizing
your code to make it run better on a
mobile devices certainly its own its own
like field stuff I would say that that's
somewhere you could just start jump in
and test it if you have a workflow that
includes you know deploying it to mobile
somehow then I would go for it and see
what you can do for sure
that's a great question though and my
answer is I don't know I test
I just just work on the web right now
and so yeah so yeah this is this is the
preload flow so this is the whole flow
of loading an asset and using asset just
to show you how it works
that's the preload function we saw it's
loading in these three audio files and
alias alias and then to these names and
then in my create section I create some
I have these paddle hit 1 and paddle hit
two and that's where I tag them in their
save when when we have pilot one it's
gonna be that audio and it's pre-loaded
so it doesn't have to load it at that
point just was making an association and
then for pong what I have here is this
is when it hits when the ball hits the
top or the bottom of the screen it makes
a certain noise and I have it I have
wall hit and it has because it's an
audio a phaser audio it has that play
method and it should play the sound and
I think if this was all hooked up right
you might actually hear the sound maybe
I had my sound turned off we can I'll
try it again but that's the flow like
that's preload create and update one
piece of code going through that hole
the whole thing so those are actually I
think update is probably the most
important part of the program here's
where everything happens it's where all
your logic is going to live it's where
everything is gonna is do if anything
interesting everything else is just set
up your preload is just building the
assets and then your create is just
saying okay put the player here put this
thing here get the ball moving here but
once the game starts running
if you didn't have anything in update it
would just run itself to exhaustion and
nothing would happen so update is where
all the fun begins
here is a slice of update for pong
itself those top two are claims that are
given to me by the by the physics model
called overlap and so when the first two
things you pass into that are two
separate objects or groups of objects
and might be if they're just objects I
have a ball object and a player object
and then the third thing is a callback
or a function that will run when that
happens and I'll talk about overlap a
little bit more a little bit later
but you can see so this when update is
called every 60th of a second this runs
just runs through and it's okay well as
the ball body is the ball at the top of
the screen or the bottom of the screen
then do this ball body velocity y x
equals minus 1 just reflects the Y
velocity it just changes direction so
it's going up now it's going down the
ball also has an X velocity which isn't
touched by that so you'll just get a
pure reflection across that and then
phaser also gives you these cursor keys
that you can simply use it gives you for
the four common cursor keys and here I'm
just checking if the cursor if the up
cursor I know it's very confusing
cursors up is down if the up cursor is
being held down or is being pressed down
while this update is running then you're
gonna move the player body up I give
give them own velocity of negative 250
so it's in the y axis negative is up and
positive is down and the x axis negative
is negative it's the lab deposits all
right so yes yes
yeah this is so update is a loop and I
think that sometimes that throws people
a little bit maybe especially people
coming from outside of front-end
development there I don't know is there
if you're if you're writing a game in
like Java or or c plus plus I think you
do this thing where you create a fake
loop you say wow one so it just runs so
it's this infinite loop that runs we
don't have to do that in JavaScript
because it's event-based already there's
already a loop going and we're just
tacking into that this does feel kind of
like a flipped version of front end loop
development like instead of adding an
event listener and then and then calling
it there that register something on the
event loop we're just we're writing a
loop itself so we're checking everything
in here and this is I mean they're
simple enough that I left them there but
you could even abstract this out a
little bit there are places where I'll
I'll show you some other abstraction I
could just say if this is happening call
a method somewhere else and it would do
the same type of thing but I just stuck
it right in there but yeah this update
is a loop this is your event loop and
what you're doing is checking for
everything that could happen in that
event loop if I put if I put like this
piece of code somewhere else outside of
update yeah it wouldn't unless you
called it from update somehow it
wouldn't so you can abstract the whole
whole class of this you could abstract
out say run this thing where you check
all the cursor keys yeah yeah you need
to at some point you did initiate that
an update that's kind of like it's kind
of like add event listener is right here
instead of instead of on the thing that
you're doing you're adding an event
listener here you're saying you're gonna
get events so look for them yeah so
that's the that's the update loop and it
can get obviously you can get pretty
complicated the update is where almost
all of your code is gonna live depending
on how crazy your game is or what you're
doing you know you're gonna want to
somehow modularize that or abstract it
out a little bit so it's easier to read
the update loop you might have your code
somewhere else so that's what I did with
with overlap actually my function
reflect lives outside of the update loop
it's written under the
it's still part of the game it's still
part of the phaser object but it's its
own function so I have like I have
preload create update and then somewhere
else I have reflect and so that's where
that's what that's calling here is it's
saying oh there's a function called
reflect let me go get that and reflect
when you call overlap it actually passes
in as the first two parameters the first
two things that you gave it so a ball
and player a ball on a career player and
I chose called a player awesome and
accurate because it can be either way
this it's doing the same thing in this
case is doing the same thing no matter
who it's so I didn't need the right one
for the player one for the computer
player although at the very bottom I
started to check because I thought you
might maybe I'd play a different sound
when a computer player gets it or maybe
I would do something differently keep
track of something but this is what
happens is and this is all this code so
the paddle is sixty pixels wide I've
listened I wanted to I wanted to make it
a kind of dynamic paddle so if you hit
it you know on one at the top or the
bottom closer to the edges it gives it
more velocity more up and down velocity
so you can kind of affect how fast the
ball is moving and try and get it moving
fast enough for the computer player
can't keep up with it so this is an
example of pulling that code out because
you could in theory if you very needed
javascript instead of writing reflect in
there I could have just written a
function right there in the in the
overlap parameter set I could have just
stuck a function in there and it would
have looked really horrible and hard to
read but this would have all been in
there this way I can actually abstract
it out and then reuse it in either case
but that's a that's a simple a simple
version of that before we get to this
maybe are there any questions about the
update loop or about how any of that
works so far I'm gonna show more
examples and talk about some more code
yeah it's it's it's really dependent on
the game itself but it should be close
to 60 frames a second and there are ways
to frame lock and
do some other things like to check see
how that's progressing if it gets I mean
I think running this and running all
this stuff I think it was having a
little trouble just keeping up the game
the browser itself or my computer but
you can generally count on it being 60
frames a second yeah these are some of
the utilities mine at the top there is
the phasor template that I use to start
a phaser game it comes with probably
more stuff than you need to just get
started but some stuff that I found
helpful some gulp stuff and some browser
or five stuff for and some testing stuff
but mainly what it comes with is that
index file it's already set up to go and
that blank phaser template and you just
our writing code that way I'd have to
keep doing it over and over again you
just get clone this as whatever you want
and and start going these are a couple
of tools I use Pixlr as an online image
editor it's great it's really simple if
you don't if you already have some like
Photoshop or camp for something
installed you can use those I don't have
those installed so whenever I need to
like manipulate an image I just fire it
fixed or calm and it'll pull images from
a URL or for the computer and and it's
pretty robust although there are some
things lacking pistol is an app that you
can either I think you can run on the
website but you can also install and
it's a sprite creation tool so when you
start doing animation you might want
sprite animation it's a great free tool
and BF XR is a weird name sound effects
tool it's very simple to use and if you
don't want to like have to worry about
finding sound files or whatever it's
it's cool you just kind of go in and say
hello it has like explosion and it gives
you a different kind of explosion and
you can very easily save those files off
and include in your game just to give it
a little bit more depth as your unless
you don't care if you don't care you
don't need any of these you definitely
don't need any of this up here to write
Fraser to program Fraser name but I
think they're nice so this is a spot
where we can talk about the tools that I
use the tool chain if that's exciting to
anybody we can I can show you some more
code first or we can just talk about
this are any of you are you guys
familiar with any of these or any of
these like weird familiar with it
all right so Express is a server
framework for node it just makes it a
little bit easier to get something
flying quickly and and I think I should
well I will show you now my my Express
server for the game is very very simple
it's 11 lines it's actually seven lines
of real code and all like I said all
that does is get me off of the file
system and give me the localhost so I
can be on HTTP and not have to run into
cross-origin stuff and if you've ever
worked with node or with Express this
might be familiar and if not it's pretty
quick to explain Express library you
have to install with NPM this is my you
know my package it's my only dependency
at this point because this is a
different the other ones have more
dependencies but so you require Express
you require HTTP I'm actually sure yeah
that's why cuz I use it to create server
you can do this a little simpler but
this is a still pretty simple make
contact because Express that's the thing
this Express stops static public is the
only extraneous library code left in
Express these days Express used to be
very full you used to have all this
stuff built in now if you want more
things you have to you have to go out
and get them but public or static is
left and all that does is instead of
having to write end points or handlers
for like when somebody comes to my
website served in this file serve them
the index file static says look I have a
folder somewhere in this case called
public and in public you will find an
index.html and anything else in public
if index that HTML asks for it just give
it to them so in the index.html you'll
see I have this jeaious bundle which is
inside my public folder so when it hits
the express server and it finds that
path it just you don't have to write
specific stuff for it you don't even
have to understand how this express
server works to use it this is the only
piece you'll probably want to know is
what port it's on in this case it's
eight thousand two because I'm running I
have several games and I
like I'd fire up node and it would say
all that ports in use and i/o which what
did I leave running so I started
separating them so I can do that
but you can put that on any port you
want and then when you go to the browser
you just do localhost colon that port
and that'll be the server that's running
there so that's the only piece of
Express code in there yes yes yeah and
it could be called anything you want
public is a is kind of idiomatic that's
the one that people use and in I'll show
you because as I was doing this I
started evolving my process I actually
started bundling and a build folder
instead public so no I well it depends
if you want them on the same web page so
then you'd like you would have them in
there somewhere for each project I have
its own folder its own like top-level
folder yeah they all have their own yeah
so like I'm in I'm in this pong folder
you know and asteroids is in an
asteroids folder so they're each their
own if you wanted to work on multiple
games at just one server one index file
you could you could certainly do it I
just separated him out to keep it easier
to think about I guess so yeah that that
was the Express we also had so gulp is a
is a build tool yes sir No so for it if
you're running as a server you would you
would use either you have node or we
were talking about - there's that
there's a thing called node Mon which
which is a kind of resilient node server
so you just had node and then the server
name or the the file that expressed
files name I call them server - by
convention but so it'd be node space
server gaius and that will run that has
its own little thing or node Mon or
whatever node you'll need node on your
computer you have to install it
depending on what system you have I used
to I think to install in fact I use
something called nvm which is a note
version manager absolutely not necessary
but pretty handy because if you start
moving our through versions
I think nodes on version 7 right now but
some stuff still wants to slip on
version 6 so if you want to take
advantage of like some cutting-edge
stuff you might want to work some things
in note 7 you might go all the way back
like node 0.10 for whatever reason to
work on something NPM is a great tool
but yet you'll you'll need to install
node yeah it should run at the command
line if it doesn't you'll need to get
into your like your whatever your
terminal node yeah no months of quick
install NPM install node Mon I install
it globally so I can use it everywhere
you can install it locally as well node
bonus is a great tool so yeah so that's
node and Express and that gets you out
of the file system so that you can you
can actually like play with this stuff
locally and not have to be like oh I'm
gonna push this up and host it somewhere
and then work on it and then so gulp is
a tool a build tool that is used to I
use it as a watcher mostly for my tests
yes sir yeah I never learned grunt so
that's why and another question is why
go up instead of web pack maybe web pack
is the new the new thing
I think gulp is very simple also in fact
I'll show you my gulp file I have it
I'll show you what I do with it
because I feel like asteroids is
probably the newest phone so I'm like I
all I use go forward to be honest to do
is my running my tests and so this is a
lemon so this is a gulp file for mocha
tests and that's the only thing I use it
for you there is a goal plugin for
browserify
and i'll talk about why use browserify
in just a second too and that would
probably be a smarter thing to do is get
go up watching all those and just doing
it all at the same time but I didn't I
didn't like the setup on that plug-in so
I just used something called walk purify
which takes browserify and turns it into
a watcher but this is gulp so with gulp
you just defined
tasks and you will usually want a
default pass and your default task will
run any other task if you want to run
whatever and the only tap real task I
have is a mocha task that pipes my code
my specific test code through a through
a mocha test runner and if you're not
familiar with unit testing or don't care
about unit testing it's not that
important
I think that unit testing and test
driven development is an incredibly
great way to develop because I think it
prevents you from screwing stuff up too
badly it helps you think about how
you're gonna build your code if you're
using it as a test-driven write your
tests and as you're writing your tests
you're actually building your logic
you're building it that way instead of
like getting really messy and building
all your logic and then and then
thinking about how to test it you're
thinking like what do I want this one
thing to do this one thing what's the
one thing I want it to do okay now I'm
gonna write that code that does that and
so this is the simple way to get into
tests I actually think this is another
reason why you should write games
because they're simple they're simple
enough that you can write unit tests for
them without worrying about like is this
a unit is this like do I have time to do
this if you're writing production code
if you're coming into something maybe
you're an existing code base and you
might not have time to think about how
to break that down into test-driven
stuff nobody may even want you to do it
and so I do think it's important and I'm
using games to teach me to be a better
test-driven developer but that's gulp in
a nutshell and I can show you what that
looks like
I'm gonna just run the mocha one because
it will run but this is it I have some
tests to do some things and the tests
pass that's not exactly what I wanted to
do so that's what happens when you run a
mocha test it tells you did it work and
so now what happens is if I go into that
code and I changed something and I save
that file the tests run again and it
breaks I know right now man the last
somewhere in the last 15 characters that
I typed in there I broke my code it's
not like a week from now or even an hour
from now when I go fire up the browser
and put play of the game it's like why
isn't when I turn left why is it turning
right what did I do
and then I have to go back and figure
out what I screwed up this tells me
right away that's one of the benefits
that's goal
so browserify in in node this concept up
here this at the top this require is a
node verb and it allows you to go get
code from somewhere else and stick it in
here like act like it actually exists
even though it doesn't exist in this
file it goes and gets it if you do this
on browser facing code your browser will
say I have no idea what require is I
don't know what you're talking about and
because I don't know what require is I
have no idea what all these other files
you're trying to use are although I
don't think it'll get that far I think
as soon as it gets require it'll just
stop there are lots of ways to
modularize your code one of them
involves just writing a bunch of script
files script tags and saying well I know
in the end I'm gonna write my app.js but
before that I have a module called math
jeaious and another one called ship
physics jeaious so you just start
putting those in there
that's okay that works but I think it's
a lot easier to use browserify and I
actually ended up writing it as a script
so this is the piece of code right here
I and you install browserify either
locally or globally again or both and
then I'm telling it when the files in
this first directory change I'll put
that bundle it up and output it into
something I'm calling bundled and what
that does is any time it hits one of
those requires it goes and finds that
code and it sticks it in the bundle so
there's no requires in my bundle there's
just all my code and all that allows me
to do is separate out things like you
know I have my app and I also might have
some utility files and the more the more
code you can pull out of your app I
think that easier it is to read your app
because if your app file gets to be
15,000 lines long and you need to go dig
in there and find something where do you
go but if you know that it's in this
like 100 line bundle somewhere 100 line
file somewhere it specifically has to do
with turning the ship right then you can
easily step through your code dig
through your code and I think you can
see more organized I like I think I mean
a lot of people I've heard
you know your function should be more
than screen long I don't think your file
should be much longer than that if you
can avoid it in some cases you can't
they shouldn't they shouldn't get so
long and it you have to scroll forever
to find stuff and so you can you can
start you can start pulling your code
out putting into separate files and then
requiring it back in so that it you can
you can use it in a very clean and
concise way and like I said none of
these things are required to do phaser
code these are just code practices yeah
yeah I mean it all depends on how you
pull it in and like what you're building
as your as your utility so in this case
I wrote this as a newer type of patterns
earlier this is a revealing module
pattern so I have some stuff and so and
this is I'm sorry if this is confusing
this is es6 Farrell notation so it might
read a little different than you might
be used to if you're using something
like this might more easily be callback
function rotation correction and then
have a parent for your parameters and
then your bracket but that's the same
essentially the same thing but you'll
see I have rotation correction and
degrees to radians and get heading in
radians but all I export is get heading
in radians so that keeps that keeps
everything else hidden they're like
private members of Java C++ guys in here
those are private methods thank you
hanging into radians is like the only
the only piece that I expose all the way
down it's not being both you couldn't
call if you require this module and you
couldn't say it like let's get the city
called the modules abilities
you couldn't the only thing you could
say is the Fillies dot get heading in
radians and you would pass it if you
said utilities dot degrees to radians
they would just say I don't know what
you're talking about I don't have this
let's do that function does not exist
yeah that's a way to keep it clean I'm
not sure to be honestly I'm not sure as
far as scope goes or what if there's any
that but we're also game developing so
scope is a little bit hazy at this point
anyways there's a lot of stuff already
you know gonna be in your scope but that
I guess the nice thing too is you can
you can choose your kind of name spacing
it in a way but I'm calling it your
heading and radiant so it's stuck in
that now the funny thing about that code
there is I actually figured that I
didn't need to do that at all I found
another way to do it but so I don't
think it's actually been recalled in
that code and
where else I would show it to you but
that's just the other reason to pull
those out into files that export things
is if you're doing unit tests you need
to be able to require those tests in in
your unit test so so like right here I
have to require it in I have to pull it
in so that I could call it and if you
just bundle all that code into the main
app then it can get kind of tricky to
pull out like what exports you want so
one of the reasons I pull code out of
the smaller pieces it's so I can test it
in smaller pieces but once again if your
testing isn't important to you or
something they're comfortable with flat
important it's not if it's not important
to game development in and of itself
just kind of an aside these are things
that I think are great to learn and I
think game doing it in a field of gamers
all that makes it a little easier and
more fun I think this is what what I
take away from writing game code is that
you're gonna make mistakes whenever you
write code you're gonna make mistakes
big mistakes small mistakes I wrote just
in the three or four games that I wrote
in the last few weeks I made a ton of
mistakes and then I would come back and
refactor them out or find them later but
the good thing is you learn if you don't
learn from the mistake itself you might
learn from having written code you
didn't need to write like all of that
right that angle correction stuff I
didn't mean it turns out I didn't need
to write it but I wrote it I learned how
to do it and now I understand
trigonometry a little better than I did
before which it's fun because I thought
I understood it pretty well and I spent
about 45 minutes thinking I knew what I
was doing and it turns out it's been way
too long since I had a trig class I
think personal projects are a much
better place to make mistakes then at
work or or even for other people work or
in front of other people I think it's
great if you can if you can learn from
your mistakes and the privacy of your
own IDE I think that makes just it's
just a little easier and then you're not
pissing off your boss or your clients or
anybody else so it's a great outlet for
making mistakes you can think like when
you've done it you know I got my quota
of mistakes for this week the more you
write especially small projects you
there's gonna be a lot of repetitive
stuff that you're doing over and over
again and so you're gonna want to find
this is something I think is an
important for every programmer is
because I think generally programmers
are very like immune to this pain they
will do it over and over again they will
type it out because it's worked it's
always what they've done I think what
you should do instead is find a way to
not have to do that if you've done
something twice figure out a way that
the next time you won't have to do it
you should never have to do it a third
time that's why I made the phaser
template because I was writing this code
I thought this is too much and then
sometimes as it evolved I'd have to go
back and think wait what did I do
did I do that right or how did I do this
now it's locked in somewhere and I can
just bring that code down and start
writing and I don't have to think about
the setup and the spool up and all this
stuff that goes into like getting things
ready that's done that's great
there are other things that you'll find
that you might be doing a lot in your
games you might be writing this may be
writing some similar games or maybe
they're not even that similar but you're
gonna find that there may be code that
you write over and over again
maybe it's subtle variations but code
that you're using over and over again
because it's a very base level piece of
code man you should write that and you
should bundle it up somewhere and you
should put it somewhere that you can say
I don't have to write that anymore I can
if you want you can copy and paste it or
I can just somehow require it and you
can just pull it in it's now you're
building your own library of functions
and code and things that you're
comfortable with I think that's great in
that ties in with the last one where
you're gonna see you're gonna know if
you're writing games that only take a
couple of days to go through and you're
doing that three or four times a week or
a month or whatever you're gonna see
those things are very frequent and are
happening very often whereas if you're
writing when I was working on react this
was in you know September the first two
weeks of September last year is when I
started this react project and I didn't
have to start another react project
until last month and it was like I had
never done it before I had no idea what
I was doing it was like wow I was
looking at my startup why did I do
things this way and do I need to do them
this way and so that's when you have
these long cycles it's hard to find
those those things and encapsulate them
and document them somehow you just think
well I'm doing it I'll do it and then
the next time all
but you want you want and so if you're
doing that a couple times a week or two
times a month you're gonna you're gonna
get sick of it a lot quicker than if
you're only doing it twice a year and
you're gonna figure out ways to make
your code reusable I think that's a
great that's a great thing those are
important parts of being a programmer is
reusable code and the more you do that
especially as you start to think like
well this works pretty much the same way
but not exactly and then I'm using it a
third time and it's slightly different
you're gonna figure out how to distill
that that essential function down into a
smaller piece of code that is extensible
in some way and this is where I'm gonna
say like rah rah functional programming
is is great if you can do that and you
can start to compose your software
you're gonna find it it's gonna be a lot
easier to do that stuff distill it down
into small pieces that you can chain
together and then when you need to chain
it together in a different way you just
take this piece out put this other piece
in and it works just how you want it to
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
every time so I think those are the
those are the big things this is my
inspirational quote the critical
ingredient is getting off your butt and
doing something it's as simple as that
I don't know how many of you know who
Nolan Bushnell is he is the co-founder
of chuck-e-cheese he also started Atari
and wrote pong the first time so that's
why it's up here but he did co-founder
quarters I think it's a great quote
that's that's the truth do it and by
doing it you're gonna learn to do it
better or you're gonna learn you don't
like to do it you'll move on to
something else but if you just think
about it I think we all do this I know I
do this I think about wanting to do it
wanting to learn something wanting to
build something but I talk about
thinking about it instead of doing it
and it doesn't get done do it yeah
so that's it this is me these are ways
you can connect with me you can might go
through my github if you want to see
some examples of interesting code or not
interesting code the phaser templates on
there and yeah any questions or anything
I didn't cover that you hope that would
cover we can look at more code running
examples I don't know what time we're at
[Music]